i have a uh a family it is a person's
family to me
with a problem and i was an enabler
you know because you want to help this
person
so much that you will do anything to
help them when you love a person
you in your mind you think i can't kick
them out
i can't i can't be there for them
it is so hard to make that switch in
your head that's how all these parents
guys
i know the switch in your head to be
like
i know you know i'm gonna tell you this
is i haven't talked about this
there's a difference right and i found
myself doing it too man
with my son it was easy because i didn't
feel like i was punishing him i felt
like i was helping him yes because he
had the skills and
and it was look you're going to struggle
but it's okay to struggle somehow we've
made struggle to be a bad word
you have to struggle struggle makes you
you're nobody's succeeding without
struggle
do you know what i mean well you're fine
if your kid comes to go dad i need yeah
man
are you trying are you trying i mean are
you trying here's my thing the enable
thing and i fell into it too
um you know my daughter just got out of
rehab and
sorry that's all right man i mentioned
it i i knew that was going on and i was
like how are you [ __ ] now
you ain't [ __ ] it was and i look at it
man and as
as as as okay
as good of decisions i think i make as a
parent man you're a beast dad
it's just hard when your kid is
struggling so much for for you uh
not to say let me help you i know
exactly because
if you say no and then i'm like oh sh
what's she gonna sleep on the [ __ ]
street tonight well like i can't do that
but you you're stuck because your brain
as a parent you know this uh right when
you have a kid your first thought is i
have to protect this person for the rest
of my life
yeah all costs no matter what so that
doesn't matter i have to get there
okay she's 26.
and has she always struggled with it
yeah she's always struggled with it man
you know her
biological mom had the same issues and
and i'm not making excuses and my
daughters had a little rough
uh run of it and she's a great person
and she's by the way through all of this
even with her struggles
never got fired from a job never lost
her job
first time wow usually it's a
reoccurring but it
was the first time she accepted it but
she she just got out this week and
and um she's doing really well she's for
the first time in a long time i feel
like
i hear hope in her voice but i hear what
you're saying it's hard when that
it's easy for me to tell you man here's
what you should do with your friend
who's an addict
oh but for me to with your daughter
it's such a difference this guy's a
brother to me you know
and i love dearly well you guys were
fighting early you know no no no no no
i'm not talking about i'm talking about
the person
no but um no but but see so for me it
was a guy who was struggling
like a brother because it was like i
have ptsd from him from dealing with
like having to call the police
uh being like you know being attacked by
this person i'm out
you know i i paid for rehab i uh you
know and it's like
you know but but it was forced you know
what i mean like they have to make the
choice themselves yeah
so the only thing i could do recently
was to be like
i have to remove myself like you don't
get my attention anymore and i i feel
like that's not a natural move
it's not watching intervention i know
the only thing i know about it now it's
like
once you the hardest choice you can make
is remove yourself yes
so they can't depend on you yes for
drugs do you know what my daughter said
to me
when she left i go what she was leaving
rehab to go to rehab
when she was leaving did you know she
had to go to rehab we
were the ones who insisted did you have
an intervention
it was just a situation where i
i was talking to beth i'm like we just
can't it's going down
we can't and how did you know it was
going down a bad road because she's 26
so she's like doing her thing man
there are some things that i just that
are that's her story that i'm not going
to share
gotcha but there were some things that
were
really tough okay yeah because you could
i could really imagine
you get tired of going you get tired of
getting calls i can't ima
i can't really listen to this i can't
listen i'm gonna speak because about
because i can speak just for me because
my own experience i'm you know excited
because i don't
you this is more personal because people
know your daughter you know
who i'm talking about people don't know
so it's fine you know but i'm saying
like
you get tired of getting you get tired
of going to the hospital
okay you get tired of going to the
hospital and a doctor saying
you should never drink again okay and
then you get tired of this
you get tired of having hope you get
tired of being disappointed
because what happens is you go oh
they're really doing good you think this
is it
oh finally they go and then you get the
call
such and such is uh we can't find such
and such you know
or you know that kind of thing you get
tired of like you know you know
just dealing with this and then then you
start having
more bad times than good
your memory gets filled with oh that
time you fell down person you
that that person that you held onto the
the the where you where you would see a
spark of that person that becomes less
and less and less and and let me tell
you the real
point for you to really start to open up
and start looking after yourself
is when you start to go because at first
you make excuses you go
you go i don't want to be around you
when you're drunk
because that's not you you know i know
the real you
when you start to realize that this is
all them mm-hmm
like they ain't two people yeah this is
24 7.
they're a person that makes bad choices
yeah and
so how's your friend doing now it's it's
up and down
like just just went through another
episode but now like you know
it's like when you have to deal with
like bipolar and like that's what all
comes from that's what mine does
like yes my daughter had to taste it
it's called dual diagnosis yes
and so my daughter had the same thing
i'm dealing with it yeah because because
what happens is
when someone's an alcoholic the reasons
why they become an alcoholic
are the things you need to deal with
because see alcohol
alcoholism you know it becomes a thing
because they're using it as
they're using it they're self-medicating
you know they self-medicate
so to get away from something yes to get
away from the pain of whatever is
causing
and then like bipolar is a [ __ ]
man and
and i feel for people that have to be on
medication because they hate being on
medication
because then you have this feeling of
like well i'm not normal because i have
to know because
i would say it dull and she was like i
hate this medication it dulls me down
it i don't feel like me and this is one
thing i will tell you
one of the reasons i have hope when i
asked my daughter i go we're coming to
get you in we're excited to come get her
and
how long was she there josh she had 90
days and um
is she married not married yeah we're
going to put her on this show
her boyfriend's a nightmare he's the
monster too she
said to me i said what what can i do to
help you and she said you can never lend
me money again
and and that was like that sounds like
somebody who knows
that no i'm not they're not because she
knows i'm not trying she could always
contact me
i'm sure both you guys with the rehab
and all that and i have a little bit of
it
going on but the problem too is the
the chances of success in rehab you look
at the success rate
oh my god it's not because it's good but
yeah because we have
okay they also have less they don't have
a drug called success rates
they also have a drug that's called i'm
not sure what the name of the drug it's
the v
and what it does is like takes away the
effects of alcohol where it tastes bad
right after one or two and then it just
tastes bad you don't get the euphor
you don't get the euphoria yeah you just
get like you know you get sick
but what that does is that's basically
just
did you know that success rate's five to
ten percent yeah i think
that's that i think that is the first
time like i think
first time in that success rate is not
great i'm not saying you're you're a
girl totally no no i totally totally
know that's going in like when you look
at the numbers like holy [ __ ] but no but
the point i'm not making
what i'm trying to make because i know
where you're at i get this because it's
like
the thing is like you you certain you
get to a point where
you you if you're a hopeful person you
get to a point where you have to be more
realistic
you get to a point where you're like
okay because that's a realistic thing
you go no i'm not giving you money
like you know so you get to a thing
where you're like hey don't ask me for
money because they're not going to get
it from me
and then they know but your fear is
sometimes your fear is
if i don't do all these things that i
wanna that i'm asked of
will they not wanna be around me anymore
will it
to tear up their relationship actually
it does the opposite really
because i would be worried let's say i
my son let's
god forbid had a issue with alcohol i
would be worried if he don't get from me
he's going to be hanging out with some
dangerous people doing some weird [ __ ]
to make that money
so at least it's coming from because
he's going to find it here's the end of
the day
the end of the day is it they don't get
better
until they hit rock bottom so the faster
you can get them there
it ends two ways man
uh what's uh even rock bottom has a
wiggle room
yeah i mean yeah yeah but here's the
thing though here's the thing
um this is what enablers do
we don't allow them to
deal with the consequences of their
actions
that's what enablers do so like if your
daughter
like say she's living in her apartment
and because of her addiction she loses
her she can't pay the rent or she can
get
about to get kicked out the enabler goes
i can't let her get kicked out yeah let
me go handle the rent
and then she never has to deal with that
never has to deal with no you have to
let her
you got to get kicked out and somehow in
your help you move yeah
but i'm not going but but here's another
that's also
right in your brain in your brain what
you justify is this
well i'm not buying a drugs i'm paying
for her rent so that's okay
but what you are tricking yourself into
thinking is the rent money went to the
drugs
that's why you're paying for the rent
correct so you are paying for her drugs
or
just for her drink or whatever it is
because they know and
addicts are master manipulators
they are the that's how they and they're
survivors they're like
yeah with your daughter doctors she's 26
i'm sure she has her own life living our
own yeah would
and you would see her how often that was
the thing you know what i'm saying like
we can hide it
we knew when we didn't have eyes on her
for a little while
or when she wasn't texting he's been a
problem since she was younger though
uh like did you see something
yes you don't have to i mean yeah i mean
like it's an intervention episode
it basically i we
she's had a rough go it's all i'm gonna
say man
that's good enough yeah yeah yeah she
had it because like just to like
generally talk about like
you know it's you know
when you're close to someone as close to
someone like
a daughter or close to someone how this
person was to me it's your best friend
it was someone like even more than a
like i said i say brother you know
because that's how close he was to me
you know
is you know when you know someone that
well
i got to a point when i knew when this
[ __ ] was drunk yeah
i'm talking about and i i i can even see
the patterns like this it would be like
because this is what happens they get
sober and just open source over then
they think i'm good
this is what happens they'll just have a
drink
casual drink it could be like let's say
you had drinks here
she could be here it's just a simple
like oh that was good then they think
i can handle this yeah and i know what
happens shortly after that
always there's a there's an episode
it's just like an episode happens it's
like you don't even know what triggers
it because
the bipolar and the thing you don't know
what triggers these people
what happens in their day where they
think i can't make it
and then the pain comes and they can't
deal with it and the only way they deal
with it is to numb it
and they numb it with this alcohol but
the problem is the drugs and alcohol
how it affects them and what happens
when they
you know they get crazy they do stupid
things they you know
they hurt themselves and those things
happen and those consequences right
there
we have to deal with them and then the
hard part too
there's one more thing the hard part too
is you learn patience
because when you when they're drunk
you want to be like what the [ __ ] are
you doing why are you doing this they
ain't listening no they're drunk they're
not going here
so now i gotta wait a week
like literally a week exhausting because
because they get off whatever and then
you have to let them recover
and then they then they're there then
there's that clarity that they have and
they're like i'm so sorry i did this
i'm never going to do this again i can't
believe i did this and then you see the
person that you love
and that's what you hold on to but i'm
saying to people
that person that was a monster that's
that [ __ ] too
here's the thing that you have to know
and this is the hardest thing
especially with people that you love it
especially
being the people that i know that we are
the feeling of being
helpless for somebody that you love is
impossible empire especially well i can
tell you for me
you know i this is somebody that i would
give my life for whatever
and even that doesn't matter
and it's so tough to it's so
because since your brain since i can
have a drink
and not have a drink for another six
months and then pick it up
it doesn't make any sense to me right
right it's harder because i don't
understand
just don't do it you can't stop right
and so
they're helpless and you're helpless
it's a disease
yeah it's really hard you know really
but if they don't recognize
they don't sometimes people are just at
a point with okay
my my friend i'm talking about
his other best friend was getting
married
all right and i had to this [ __ ]
was drunk
the day before what i had to go through
to get this [ __ ] to her wedding
i'm i'm engaged practically and i just
got to get this ring but she's [ __ ]
terrible i don't want that ring i want
this ring anyway
i told my i told him i said you ain't
coming to my wedding
if you're not i'm not talking about
sober for a day
i gotta know that you're yeah i gotta
know or you're not gonna be invited
and that's the only thing you could do
because
the only power we have is that
first of all you have to recognize we
can't solve it
nope so let it go that's it we can't
solve it all right
but what you can take away as as
punishment i guess is the best word to
use or or it's just show like hey this
is what you're losing repercussions yeah
there has to be repercussions
and the repercussions are you
you know it's like it's it's the time
it's like now you can't
have you seen my kid or you can't you
can't no you can't
hey we're having thanksgiving you're not
invited yeah you're not invited
because you're this way and because they
have to
feel yeah the repercussions of their
actions
because if they don't feel those
repercussions they keep doing it if
you're always saving them
yeah then they don't they're like oh
because they find enablers have you
find enablers have you gone to allanon
meetings at all
can i tell you something they they they
did man i'm just i haven't they haven't
helped me what's the
meaning it's
loved ones of the attic and it really
does help man you sit there perspective
perspective it makes you feel not alone
it makes you feel not as crazy
you're like oh you're doing i you did
the same thing i'm doing like it really
even just talking about these
experiences shared experiences it really
doesn't even hearing you say this makes
me feel like oh yeah i know exactly what
you're going through yeah yeah and you
need that support you know
i didn't go because not that i'm famous
or anything you know
i'm not saying you know but i just
didn't want to be in there and somebody
being like oh my taste what you doing
yeah so i i go to therapy you know i was
going to therapy and it was like it
became like a theme of my therapy of
talking about like
it's like why am i feeling like i'm
responsible why am i and
i realized i was like i'm just saying my
fault no i'm not
impossible but you're a good dude and
it's in your nature to love your friends
and your family and to fix
so but with your daughter is it was it i
keep going to your daughter but
i can't edit it out if you want but is
it was the group she hanging
are they all enablers like her friends
because to me if i if i'm your daughter
i'm that person with this disease
it's like my friends are drinking like
how the like those are my friends man
yeah but i don't have the power to say
no so what am i supposed to change my
life completely
yeah yeah 26. check it out you know what
i'm seeing like
she's [ __ ] nightmare she um
is not the most she's a little socially
awkward a lot of that has to do with the
bipolar and the combination
yeah and she's she um trust issues so so
she and she
look man you know her biological mom and
all that stuff
she's had like i said she had a rough go
coming up and the addiction's inherited
right
i i think you get the chip yeah like you
can get the chip
yeah but i but for me that might be bro
science
yeah i might have just made no i do
think you there is a gene
pretty sure i do think so but but
she there are a couple people in her
life who were
enabled and but that's the thing most
people aren't equipped
they just think oh i can change you
can i tell you something though they
don't have respect
for those people it's why they chose
them in the first place
sure interestingly and so don't be
here's the thing yeah addiction is to do
50 genetic predisposition
that's a lot that's a lot yeah what i'm
saying is
don't be don't be one of those people
children of addicts are eight times more
likely to develop
but what i'm saying is don't be one of
those people that they don't respect
because that's why they it has to be
like it's like you know your friends who
know not to ask you for money
you know there's people that are just
like they would never they know better
you know better
some people that they go when you're you
know when you try to get over on someone
yeah you know when you're trying to get
over and if they if you allow
if when you're when you once you get it
you have a feeling about that person
yep got you yeah and addicts are like
that
you know and by the way this is kind of
full circle for me one of my best
friends ever in the world who was the
biggest addict i ever met
joey diaz left town today but man
i i used to watch him you know when he
was
deep into the coke that's what his day
revolved around he was consumed by it
how this is how much money i know i need
to buy this amount of coke and like and
and he was the master i
like watching him and he used to be able
to manipulate
people so well he was part of his i mean
he's one of the most charming
[ __ ] going right
but you added that addictive chip um
and i watched him for years and i i did
learn
a lot and i always thought man
i'll never i'll never i'll never and
then here comes my daughter and i did
all the things
yeah they tell you not to that i said
it's hard man
i said it you can't imagine it's hard
it's a hard thing it's like you know
just
you know when you when you at it you
know what just to be
on a lighter subject of it is you know
people
like on a show like 90 day fiance and
you see these people
that get involved with someone and you
go why would you put yourself in this
situation and they all say the same
thing
i love them mm-hmm you know
that i mean what that does to your brain
oh my god and what you
do i think what to decide you what you
decide to put up with and yeah
and the compromises you make yeah it's
very similar yeah you're right it's very
similar you go well i have to do this
and you just go you don't
you don't know and even though like and
outside people are always like i had
you know and my buddy was living with me
for a little while you know and i had
you know this the other people i'll
never forget this he's in rehab
going to visit his some friends came to
see and everybody's like you know
and they all looked at they were they
said oh great but my friends the friends
looked at me and said
how are you because you know you got to
take care of yourself too and i'm and at
the time i was like what are you talking
about i'm fine
i'm not the one in rehab right yeah i
get it now yeah
i get it now because it's about because
that didn't even work
because like a lot of times the rehab
choice to me
has to be it's it's the rock bottom and
they have nowhere else to go
you know they have to ask for it you
know
i mean what do i do because you've lost
my support
you've lost your support system you keep
waking up in hospitals
yeah at what point are you going to be
like hey
what's rock bottom yeah do you not want
to wake up in the hospital anymore yeah
but they know they could just get on the
phone and be like you know hey
i need you know yep and then and then
what do you do that's that heartstring
that's hard to deal with and that's why
alanon
i recommend anybody that's still
listening to this right now
it's just going to get therapy it's not
a bad thing
we shun therapy but being in therapy is
important sometimes
because therapy is not going to solve
your problems but it's going to help you
organize your thoughts
it's going to help you analyze the
reasons why you're feeling the way
you're feeling
with an expert who understands it can
connect the dots
it's not always about going in there and
being like help me save me
it's about really
having a clear thought and seeing how
the dots are connected
and that stuff's important and having
conversations and opening up
and and just being of you know
vulnerable
like how we all have been even in this
moment talking about this
is really important and helpful and i
hope
if you're thinking about doing it out
there i would recommend you
push you to go do it yeah but when i get
off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son